I think the problem is that it's true
what's true that there are differences
between men and women psychologically
this is true and it sort of doesn't
matter whether or not you think that
that truth might be misused by Bad
actors I don't think we solve anything
by trying to pretend otherwise and I
think also that when you
withdraw from a discipline like say
evolutionary psychology which makes
feminists are very suspicious of
what you end up doing is having no
ability to contribute to that discipline
if anyone with a kind of feminist
Incarnation rushes out of discipline you
sort of Leave It to the you leave it to
the Bad actors you're likely to actually
produce more dodgy anti-feminist science
because you've just you've given up I
mean that's defeatist arguably right
yeah I think we should say
the science is morally neutral
if it's true it's true what we decide to
do with that truth is up to us